we are also following new developments
in the investigation into the overnight
plane crash in Iran officials say there
were no survivors there unverified video
from Iranian TV appears to show the
Ukraine International Airlines flight on
fire before it went down in a field just
after takeoff on the city outskirts 176
people were on board Kris Van Cleave is
following this story Kris what have you
learned so far good morning
well good morning a lot of unanswered
questions here the Boeing 737 was less
than three years old it was not a 737
max Ukrainian international airline says
the plane was in good working order and
was flown by one of its most experienced
crews now take this part with the
appropriate amount of skepticism but
Iranian officials are indicating a
mechanical issue possibly a engine fire
may have brought down flight 752
it happened just hours after Iran
attacked two US military bases in Iraq
most of the 176 on board were Iranian
but among the dead are 63 Canadians no
Americans were on board whatever went
wrong happened fast within just a few
minutes of taking off for Kiev video of
the crash site shows flames and debris
scattered across a field crews have
reportedly found the black boxes but
Iran will not give boeing access to them
the route from Tehran to Kiev is popular
with Iranian students the Boeing 737-800
generally has a strong safety record
this morning Boeing calls the crash a
tragic event saying our heartfelt
thoughts are with the crew passengers
and their families normally Boeing FAA
and NTSB would assist with a crash
investigation but given the tensions
with Iran this will not be a normal
investigation now just prior to the
crash the FAA restricted US flights from
using airspace over Iraq Iran and other
areas in the Middle East
several foreign airlines including Air
Canada are also now avoiding that
airspace Anthony all right Chris thank
you very much
you